zuerst etwas vorab dieser vortrag ist
etwas seltsam
insofern ist nämlich nicht wie es in der
philosophie eigentlich sein sollte einen
ganz bestimmten gedanken in dem vortrag
entwickeln will sondern weil es ihr um
ein ja ein workshop geht der überhaupt
erst das feld der philosophie des
digitalen zu vermessen und zu bestimmen
hat will ich jetzt versuchen so etwas
wie einen überblick zu geben der die
bandbreite möglicher phänomene und
probleme mit denen wir uns philosophisch
zu befassen haben ins auge passt also
insofern bleibt alles sehr kursorisch
sehr tätig sollte aber die vielfalt des
des feldes und der fragen klar machen
vielleicht noch kurz davor ab etwas zu
eigenen methodik meiner meinung nach ist
eine kritik der technischen lebenswelt
weniger obwohl philosophen dass in
dieser frauen sehr lieben
in der form durchzuführen dass man die
mythen die trans humanistischen
ideologien die disziplin die utopie dass
abholung geht ist das apokalyptische
hervorhebt also im grunde genommen eine
art ideologiekritik der digitalität
macht genau das möchte ich nicht sondern
ich glaube dass gerade die philosophie
die aufgabe hat wirklich die medien
technologischen bedingungen als real
phänomene zu reflektieren und wenn ich
von real wendungen spreche dann meine
ich auch nicht nur die irritierenden ich
nenne es mal spitzenprodukte künstlicher
intelligenz ins auge zu fassen sondern
genau die alltags techniken die
kulturtechniken unserer lebensformen die
unter den bedingungen des digitalen sich
verändern genau die sollten in den fokus
treten und das zumindest ist meine
eigene praxis logische herangehensweise
an die frage der digitalität
so ich hier haben sie eine gliederung
ich lese die jetzt nicht vorbei ich ja
dann zu den einzelnen punkten kommen
tatsächlich habe ich versucht das
gesamtgebiet der des digitalen auf 11
zusammenhänge hin zu selektieren
ich hätte zwanglos noch zehn weitere
hinzu zu fügen gehabt aber unterlassen
das natürlich ist auch schon eine
ziemliche menge und ich hoffe wir kommen
trotzdem in mehr oder wegen der 20
minuten oder einer halben stunde
wer durch so ich mache das jetzt damit
mir synchronität ist so dass ich
tatsächlich so ist immer die folie leese
um sie dann kurz zu kommentieren
die kritik der digitalität als kultur
wissens und lebensfroh die kritik wie
die philosophen gerne sagen ich finde
den titel nicht gut die kritik digitalen
per unvernunft ist immer auch eine
kritik
und darauf kommt es mir an der medien
vergessenheit der philosophie
selbstkritik ich werde mich dazu nicht
weiter äußern habe ich mehr daran
erinnern heißt ambivalenzen zu erkennen
und zu zu lassen also kritik auf sich
selber anzuwenden und das heißt unsere
welt nicht im register des entweder oder
sondern ein sowohl als auch zu erfassen
kurzer kommentar dass die philosophie
genuin durch eine große medien
vergessenheit charakterisiert ist wissen
im grunde genommen alle die medien
technologische reflektion erreichte
philosophie zuletzt wahrscheinlich
gründe dass in der attraktivität des
linguistic turn bei dem die philosophie
glaubt mit ihrer bezugnahme auf sprache
schon genügend bezugnahme auf die welt
des symbolischen vielleicht auch der
medien geleistet zu haben der witz aber
ist dass unsere abendländische
philosophie also dass philosophie modell
in das wir alle hinein sozialisiert
wurden und das darin besteht das
philosophieren heißt bekannt zu machen
und zu argumentieren
dass dieses philosophie modell genuin
verknüpft ist mit der entwicklung der
alphabetischen schrift im antiken
griechenland
das ist ein eigenes thema muss sich auf
seite lassen aber hätte nur weil es in
griechenland keine buch religion gab
konnte der text überhaupt so einen
freiraum werden und den spielraum geben
um antagonistische positionen eines für
und wider die sie in gerichtsverfahren
mündlich der zahl waren im antiken
griechenland jetzt in dem raum des
textes zu übertragen und das ging eben
nur im medium er schrift wir wüssten von
sokrates kaum etwas wenn nicht durch
platons schritt technik
so ich gehe gleich weiter ich möchte im
folgenden drei basale begriffe klären
wohl wissen dass ich darum eine große
debatte entspinnt aber ich vermute
dennoch dass es drei zentrale begriffe
wie die einen kern einen historischen
kern haben und in denen ich gerne noch
mal erinnern würde ich mache das jetzt
für die begriffe digital für den begriff
des algorithmus und für den begriff des
datums warum ich tatsächlich
ratifizierung und nicht etwa den
computer für das camp phänomen gegenwart
der digitalität halte dazu komme ich
dann auch später also hier zuerst
digitalen digital bedeutet die zerlegung
eines kontinuums in voneinander
unabhängigen beziehung zu einheiten
dekodiert und miteinander kombiniert bzw
kombiniert werden können das typische
beispiel für einen solchen vorgang also
für die prozessuale der digitalisierung
ist das alphabet wenn sie uns den
schluss des sprechens pornographisch
aufzeichnen werden sie merken das ist
zwar pausen gehen nämlich um ihr atem
holen dass diese pausen aber in keiner
weise übereinstimmen mit den board
abständen und erst recht nicht mit dem
motto zwischen den buchstaben
tatsächlich ist es also erst das system
der alphabetischen schritt ist dadurch
identifiziert nicht sogleich ans hbf zu
sein
es ist erst das system der
alphabetischen schritt der kav ist muss
dieser art von schrift dann die sprache
zu einem system machte das aus dem
gesamt ereignis von kommunikation mit
ihrer mimik gestik und so weiter das ist
übrigens auch das diesen verbalen strang
der kommunikation zu so etwas wie
sprache
beobachtbar macht und der
gegenständlichen letzt es ist also ist
da tatsächlich die idee ist es ist die
schrift die überhaupt erst die sprache
als solitär und gegenstand von analysen
sektion hervorbringt und diese schrift
ist die frühform ist digitalen ich komme
als dieses typische ein kontinuum
indiskrete elemente zu unterteilen
ich komme hier zum begriffserklärung
algorithmus abgeleiteten schwarzen in
dem namen des arabischen gelehrten des
islamischen gelehrten der das von
kindern und mit dezenten position system
nach europa transferiert
ein algorithmus ist ein regel
interpretations freies in taktischer
zeichen manipulation und darauf kommt es
an
die von menschen oder malchin realisiert
werden kann
ich muss das nicht lange ausführen wenn
sie in römischen ziffern und zu 566 mal
787 aufrechnen sollen das schriftlich
nicht sie brauchen dafür einen abakus
das geht aber im pc-markt positions-
system das heißt also dieses von einem
paravent nach spanien transferierte
position system das an die römischen
ziffern nach einem langen kultur kampf
um die null ging verdrängte
diese position system erlaubt ein rein
schriftliches rechnen und damit wird die
rechen regel als an regel zu zeichen
transformation überhaupt erst konkret
und wird also als schwarz nie diese
eigenname wurde laut initiiert so
algorithmus oder algorithmen
ich komme mir zur begriffsklärung daten
auch ein heiß umstrittenes fällt es gibt
vorab es gibt keine hohen daten im
begriff des data mining zum trotz karten
sind ab numerische werte die ein wohl
bestimmten ort innerhalb eines wissens
systems einnehmen und dadurch erstleser
und informativ werden beispiel heutiges
kalender datum
wir wissen alle dass diese zahlenfolge
27.05.2011 als datum des heutigen tages
und dem aus wir übrigens mechanisch nach
vorne und auch noch zurückgehen können
dass dieses datum des heutigen tages nur
lesbar ist semantisch erfüllt werden
kann im horizont einer kalender praxis
und diese kalender praxis ist natürlich
eine kulturelle praxis aber ihr
entspricht auch etwas gegebenes datum
gas gegeben
auch die maya hatten 1 kalender das
mexikanische antike folgt das 365 tage
umfasste war in der sozialen kalender
praxis sich zugleich die physik unseres
astronomischen systems bewegen der erde
um die sonne
sozusagen nieder auskristallisiert also
insofern ist die wechselwirkung von
physischen realität und kultureller
konstruktivität gerade dann bin ist so
um das verständnis von daten geht
unbedingt zu berücksichtigen sodass
waren auch schon mal begriffserklärungen
sie sehen ich gehe schnell durch war
ursprünglich war ja engagiert wir
sollten viel zeit zur diskussion haben
das haben wir dann auch immer noch und
ich gehe jetzt gleich zu meiner nächsten
folie auch die hat einen leitgedanken
also um es gleich zu sagen dass digitale
ist vom computer ablesbar
im übergang von der alphanumerischen zu
digitalen realität zeigt sich und sie
sehen darauf kommt es mir an diese
kultur technische umwandlung von
buchdruck kultur zu digitalität zeigt
sich dass italy tät in keilform bereit
sind alphanumerischen praktiken angelegt
das beispiel alphabetische sortierung
also das alphabet hat seinen weltweiten
siegeszug nicht deshalb angetreten weil
es ein fotografisches schriftsystem ist
also also das sprechen ein stückweit
transkribiert sondern auch wann ist zb
eine ideale form einer gartenbank
technik ist in der große konvolute an
wissen informationen so zu sortieren
sinn das von spreche jetzt in jaguar von
nutzerinnen auf problemlose weise
zugriff auf die einzelnen bausteine
genommen werden können wie zb in einem
dieser früheren dicken telefonbücher
also die alphabetische sortierung ist
dein datenbank prinzip ab und gartenbank
prinzip heißt ihr sie merken es geht mir
um spur
riesige datenbank prinzip heißt hier
nicht narrativ narrativ ist ein text in
der ein anfang ein ende und eine gewisse
folgerichtigkeit mittendrin aber in
einer datenbank werden die elemente nach
einem sortierung prinzip machen register
angeordnet wer wenn man so will abitur
konventionell ist und dann
verschiedenartige formen der sortierung
und des zugriffs ermöglicht worum es mir
aber geht ist dass der umgang mit diesem
frühen datenbank prinzip eine der
erstrangigen gelehrt praktiken der
körper also etwa die entwicklung mit der
wir immer wieder die rohen die moderne
einsetzen lassen enzyklopädie nach
diesem prinzip sortiert wörter mich
sowieso hand wünscht auch es entwickelt
sich sagt im 13 jahrhundert technik
konkordanz und un zu machen biografien
und vor allen dingen es gibt die zicke
kasten technik von luhmann mit leistung
man besonders bekannt aber auch leisten
sap passten ist es war ein historischer
sonderfall in seinem ganzen umfang ist
heute erhalten
alles ist also um klar zu machen dass
digitale beginnt mich erstmal der
computernutzung
jetzt aber ist jetzt aber ist die frage
was überhaupt ist neu und ich sehe
gerade entschuldigen sie da ist mir eine
folie ich muss ich wollte die umgestellt
haben das habe ich nicht hier in es
weiter mit dieser folie müssen da noch
mal zurück springen ich frage mich jetzt
dennoch was überhaupt ist neu und es ist
klar dass wenn wir uns nach dem neuen
der computergenerierten digitalität
fragen haben wir ein quartett von
bedingung zu beachten
aus deren zusammenspiel erst reagiert
was digitale die t tauss macht oft
einzigartige ist also ein zusammenspiel
von sensor technologie
das ist das berühmte wittes computing
ratifizierung
und ich hab das mal genannt high
performance brechen
das also ist die ausgangsbedingungen
daraus aus deren zusammenspiel dieser
faktoren entsteht etwas und das was
entsteht ist jedenfalls in meiner
perspektive das folgende digitalität
bild eine neuartige symbolische form die
ich zitiere hans blumenberg lesbarkeit
er wählt verwandelt sich in die
maschinen lesbarkeit bis daten
universums das ist die these die mich
sehr beschäftigt in sie sehen schon an
dieser these von der lesbarkeit der welt
zur maschinen lässt und an die
sauberkeit des daten universums das
offensichtliche begriffs datums und der
defizite da eine besonders große rolle
spielt wer jetzt aber weitergehen
springe ich noch mal zurück es tut mir
leid da hab ich jetzt selber etwas bin
ich etwas durcheinander in mein folien
gekommen
hole jetzt noch etwas nach was mir aber
sehr wichtig ist
damit sie das folgende bestehen ich habe
das genannte ethik assistenz ob der
begriff der ethik hier wirklich
angemessen ist weiß ich nicht
das verhältnis von mensch maschine ist
nicht nach dem modell der substitution
der wechselseitigen assistenz bzw
performance zu konzipieren bei welcher
menschen das ist mein steak mit
sozusagen das sehen andere anders die
kontrollierende und entscheidende
instanz sind beziehungsweise bleiben
sollte
in nahezu allen philosophischen aber
auch den übrigen geisteswissenschaftlich
auseinandersetzung mit der technologie
residiert im hintergrund ein modell der
idee dass die technik das beginnt mit
kaplan verstärkung optimierung
menschlicher leistungen sei und
schließlich und mit gewisser konsequenz
zur ersetzung des menschen führen obwohl
das in gewisser weise in bestimmten
franken bereichen gilt gilt es doch für
die meisten technologien als grundlagen
prinzip nicht ich kann bisschen länger
ausführen aber schon ein blick auf die
energietechnologie auf defekt ihres
technologie die wir kaufen also eine
extrapolation verstärkung menschlicher
lauf tätigkeit ansehen können belehrt
uns dass die idee der technik als
ersetzung menschlicher leistungen zu
kurz greife sie ist nicht einfach falsch
aber sie greift zu kurz
und mein vorschlag ist das insofern vor
also jetzt sag ich das doppelt gemoppelt
mein vorschlag ist also aber das kommt
nicht das klingeln oder die straße
einlassen ob es immer wieder auch mal
pizza eingeblendet für die kleine
verwirrung
aber mein vorschlag ist das verhältnis
von mensch und technik im horizont des
konzeptes einer wechselseitigen
assistenz zu fassen
inklusive der darin implizierten
kontroll humanen kontrollinstanz mir ist
klar dass das eine debatte ist mir ist
klar dass diese wenigen hinweise
überhaupt nicht berühren um auch daraus
ein vernünftiger ansatz der reflektion
des mensch technik behältnisses oder der
coupe performance des mensch technik
verhältnis zu entwickeln aber mensch und
technik von anbeginn als ein sozusagen
aktionsbündnis zu sehen als ein paar
reden machen ja biene teilen
verschiedenartig erteilt des
aktionsbündnis zu sehen und das dass es
den menschen zum menschen macht dass er
genau diese und an beginnen seine
tätigkeit sei es in der welt seins sein
dasein diesen aktions verhältnis auf
diesen variablen aktions behältnissen
menschen wohnen und technik beruht dass
wir das denken müssen als horizont auch
um das digitale zu verstehen
darauf kommt es mir eigentlich klar ist
auch dass ich damit nicht mich als eine
vertreterin der equinet
da gibt es gewichtige unterschiede aber
die lassen wir jetzt auf seite ich muss
jetzt leider wieder eine folie nach
vorne so jetzt kommen wir zu mal zu dem
wir sind es also in dieser frage was ist
neu und ich möchte diese frage nach dem
neuen der gegenwärtigen digitalität
zuerst einmal es theologisch angehen
indem ich von einer epidemiologie der
latenz sprecher wobei ich habe jetzt
literaturhinweise in der folie lassen
metro kirshenbaum aber auch stephanie da
hier in deutschland haben glaube ich
diesen gekürzten aufgebracht ich zitiere
das auch wenn ich öffentlich schreibe
aber eben jetzt hier in der folie nicht
ich möchte dass nur sagen die eine
epidemiologie der latenz glaube ich ist
nicht meine eigener das sollte man
wissen aber was sich dahinter verbirgt
und das ist jetzt schaffen hunden als
eigene ist der folgende satz computer
fungieren die mikroskope und teleskope
im garten universum und sie können als
forensische also muss das sichernde
maschinen und intendierte spuren in
unserem kulturellen praktiken explizit
machen
es ist völlig klar dass das nicht die
einzige aufgabe der muster
identifizierenden und transformieren
maschine namens computer ist aber eine
der ganz wesentlichen und ich möchte
dass anna nie einfach ein beispiel und
alle die beispiele die jetzt auch folgen
die aus über grob bereiche digital
humanities und so weiter kommen sind
immer zu denken als grob
holzschnittartige einfache modelle die
nur etwas klar machen sollen
würde etwa mein ausgezählt nicht nach
speziellen betroffen wie zb
schriftlichkeit oder symbolische
maschinen sondern würden
für uns worte die präpositionen etwa die
ich benutze oder und
und so weiter würden die ausgezählt und
schließlich eine liste gemacht
die angeordnet ist nach der grössten
häufigkeit und so weiter und so fort in
dieser rangliste entsteht also eine
liste die die wort häufigkeiten der
funktions worte in meinem aufzählt und
darstellt dann wäre es möglich auf diese
weise so etwas wie bitte nation zeichen
ein fingerabdruck von mir als autorin zu
erzeugen
der ist dann möglich macht wenn ein
anonymer tipp von mir erschien mit einer
gewissen aber immer nur statistischen
wahrscheinlichkeit woher es an zu können
ob dieser text von mir ist oder nicht
ich habe keinerlei bewusstsein wie ich
meiner sprache wie ich meine sprache auf
dieser mikroebene der funktions worte
überhaupt einsetzen
das geschieht einfach im regen und im
schreiben
gleichsam zeigt sich in diesem stil
etwas sprachlich unbewusstes in meiner
art der artikulation der mit meiner
identität verknüpft ist obwohl ich
selber darüber kein bewusstsein haben
und ich möchte diese kleine geschichte
die jetzt vor mir als unwesentlich im
auto handelt dass sie die extrapolieren
auf situationen in denen es um mehr geht
als um wesentliche gesichtspunkte nahezu
alle verfahren es so genannten data
mining die sowohl einlesen analysieren
aus der entfernung von bildern wie von
texten beinhalten haben
die option
unter umständen muster zu tage zu
fördern von denen wir in unseren
absichtsvolle nen symbolischen praktiken
noch kein bewusstsein haben und ich
möchte ihnen als ein beispiel dafür
etwas sagen auf das sich selber erst
kürzlich jetzt gestoßen bin wie viele
andere oder fast alle die sich mit dem
digitalen beschäftigen ist roberto busa
der das war einführung so jesuitenpater
aus italien
roberto busa ist die galionsfigur eines
pioniers bild digital humanities doch
ich bin jetzt in meinen eigenen
forschungen noch auf eine weitere person
gestoßen nämlich zu viel miles auf die
ich auch später noch immer kommen werde
der ist gelungen ist tatsächlich durch
tätigkeiten des wörter zählen die sie
teilweise mit dem computer teilweise
aber auch selber eigenständig
inländischer arbeit sozusagen realisiert
hat durch dieses große zeh auszählen von
worten einzelner autoren oder ganze
epochen wichtige theoreme ihrer
disziplin
es war die literaturwissenschaft in
bezug auf einzelne autoren oder in bezug
auf gattungen und epochen zu revidieren
ich werde noch einmal darauf
zurückkommen aber schon hier möchte ich
klar machen dass die frage was trägt es
eigentlich worte zu zählen und die
cities handel natürlich nicht nur von
gott erzählen aber eben auch darum was
also dieser simplen qualifizierenden
methoden dann wenn man ganz bestimmte
fragestellungen hat
durchaus sinn machen können so wie sie
für andere und viele andere
fragestellungen ohne sinn sind ich gehe
weiter es gibt ein weiterer aspekt der
epidemiologie der latenz ich habe das
bisher genannt der stachel des digitalen
kann als korrektur des
geisteswissenschaftlichen und auch
philosophischen selbstbildes dienen
die mit der hermeneutik als
alleinstellungsmerkmal ertränkten betone
das geht hier um verdrängte tätigkeiten
geisteswissenschaftliche arbeit also
dass wir überhaupt werke texte
musikstücke in irgendeiner form sammeln
müssen dass sie datiert werden müssen an
notiert werden katalogisiert editiert
und so weiter und so fort
diese materialen grundlagen einerseits
werden vertreten und können aber
zusammen mit den impliziten konventionen
der buch kulturen unserer lektüre
praktiken andererseits in digitalisate
also durch den zwang zu digitalisieren
offensichtlich gemacht werden
auch das ist ein riesen fällt mir geht
es darum dass der zwang
sagen wir mal bereits im kulturellen
gedächtnis vorhandene texte noch dem der
digitalen bearbeitung zugänglich zu
machen erfordert diese texte einer
umschrift zu unterwerfen so kann man
sagen aber diese umschrift ich habe als
beispiel die markup language also von
dieser als beispiel genannt die eben
eine auszeichnung sprache ist mit der
implizite konventionen die unseren
umgang mit texten ziemlich jetzt einmal
auf texte regeln explizit gemacht werden
ein einfaches beispiel wenn die lesen
ist es für uns völlig klar dass die
kapitelüberschrift ein anderes genre
innerhalb des tags des schriftbildes
verkörpert als die stacks des kapitels
es ist klar dass was fußnote ist wieder
zu einem anderen genre gehört und so
weiter und so fort es müssen abschnitte
markiert werden also alle diese schweiz
stillschweigenden konventionen alles
dieses implizite wissen zum beispiel
über das was ein eigenname ist und der
im schriftbild normalerweise
hervorgehoben wird dieses implizite
wissen eigentlich muss wenn der text
maschinen lesbar gemacht werden soll
muss er explizit gemacht werden und
damit haben wir also die möglichkeit als
geisteswissenschaftlerin das was als
implizites wissen in unserem umgang mit
symbolischen artefakten verkörpert ist
auf die oberfläche ist artifiziellen
oder der der daten korporal zu heben die
dann von maschinen zu bearbeiten sind
ich komme und hab das ja jetzt schon
ausgesprochen zu den digital humanities
ein gerade für die philosophen
provokantes ambivalentes gebiet ist und
ich würde gerne als erster aussage dazu
ein unterschied klar machen um ihn dann
aber auch wieder ein wenig zu
relativieren
zwischen der kulturtechnik digitalität
tag normal zwischen dem umstand dass jal
am bildschirm arbeiten müssen wenn wir
überhaupt ist wieso von
geisteswissenschaftler heute noch und
artikulieren wollen
zwischen der kulturtechnik digitalen
vitalität einerseits und daten getrieben
war
quantifizieren der forschungs methodik
mit der ich wirklich die digital
humanities jetzt gerne definieren würde
ist zu unterscheiden
klar ist aber wie bei allen christlichen
unterscheidungen das ist nur ein
spektrum wir können also sagen auf der
einen seite steht die bildschirm
arbeiten in e mails im filesharing in
der nutzung der digitalen ressourcen die
für uns alle zum alltag geworden ist und
am ende des spektrums stehen eben die
quantifizieren daten getriebener
forschungsmethoden digitimes die also
wirklich algorithmisch bearbeiten sind
und auch ihr algorithmen selber
verändern
in dieser arbeit zusammen lernen
algorithmen sind aber das ist im grunde
ein spektrum aber mir ist es wichtig
klarzumachen dass dies nicht etwa heißt
jemand auch für new energies gelehrte
arbeiten mit digitalen quellen oder
arbeiten mit artikulieren sich e mails
sondern das gestrichene thies würde ich
sagen nicht das große zelt ist wie das
manchmal das patent jetzt manchmal
gesagt mit sondern tatsächlich nicht
weil hat die klar artikulierte
kombination aale verfahren zur
bearbeitung galotti mehr geistes ist ich
hab mich auf fragestellungen bedeutet
und ich komme dann zu dem zweiten punkt
digital humanities sind dann auch nicht
konkurrieren
und erst recht nicht ersetzen also immer
dieser ersetzung diskurs
ich sag jetzt mal was außerhalb des
kriegt mich das auf wie die wii
zentriert geisteswissenschaftler inhalt
sind in ihrer angst dass etwas was
technisch innovativ ist verdrängen sie
verdrängen und ersetzen könnte stadt zu
sehen das neue optionen sich entwickeln
und in diesem fall sind ich wollte es ja
vorlesen das ist jetzt das den zweiten
punkt vor
die digital humanities sind nicht
konkurrieren sondern komplementär zu den
traditionellen geisteswissenschaften und
ich hatte ihn eben die pioniere news
vielmals die übrigens die erste
lebenszeit professorin genannt die eben
noch vor roberto busa zählende verfahren
eingesetzt hat um wichtige theoreme
ihrer disziplin zu korrigieren zu
kritisieren zu korrigieren durch andere
sichtweisen zu ersetzen so ich sage oh
das sehr spannend wäre dazu jetzt aber
nichts weiter sondern komme jetzt zu
einem weiteren gesichtspunkten könnte
man vielleicht auch die ontologie nennen
die metamorphose sind bullisher form in
duncan korporal also ich habe das schon
gesagt sage dass es noch mal als these
auch geisteswissenschaftliche
forschungsobjekte erfahren eine
umschrift um überhaupt der digitalen
bearbeitung und übrigens auch nach
nutzung zugänglich zusammen aus
symbolischen objekten eigentlich unsere
zu schädigen werden danken korporal und
aus diesen werden statistisch analysiert
menge im koordinatensystem ich gebe
ihnen ein extrem vereinfacht das
beispiel erlauer bitte weggucken aber es
ist trotzdem schlagen mir geht es darum
zu erkennen dass datenpunkte sind und
deshalb hab ich jetzt diese folgende
grafik einen lern algorithmus soll
katzen und hunden unterscheiden kennen
sie alle wird vielfach diskutiert packt
dich heißt das natürlich ihr wenig katze
nun
unterschieden sondern der lern
algorithmus entwickelt eine
mathematische update funktion die die
punkte die daten die katzen präsentieren
und die daten die hunde repräsentieren
einigermaßen einigermaßen sortiert um
dann mit statistischer
wahrscheinlichkeit von zwischen 90 und
95 prozent zu sagen sie es ist eine
katze
es sind also punkte die hier in einem
koordinatensystem eingetragene übrigens
das koordinatensystem wurde
bekannterweise ist kt sische koordinaten
von bekannten suchen rené descartes
erfunden und das worauf es hier ankommt
ist das zweierlei zum ersten ich finde
das extrem interessant dass vilém
flusser in philosoph ja die these
vertreten hat dass das universum der
schrift und des buches durch die linie
gekennzeichnet sei aber wir jetzt im
übrigen zu einem punkte universum wären
und dass ich glaube dass daten pumpte in
den weg zu räumen oder wie man das auch
immer nennen soll in in
koordinatensysteme zu punkten
koordinaten systemen werden um sie
überhaupt maschinell bearbeiten zu
können halte ich für eine interessante
von plus und natürlich unvorhergesehene
untermauerung seiner idee wichtig ist
natürlich auch das sehen sie wunderbaren
diesem bild es ist nur eine statistische
wahrscheinlichkeit es gibt also hunde da
drüben bei den katzen katzen trugen bei
den hunden und das erspare ich ihnen
jetzt es gibt ein sticker netz habe ich
im netz im internet gefunden wo diese
diese grafik so gebraucht wird das
plötzlich die statistik verschwindet und
nur noch eindeutig katze und hund
sortiert werden was ein system niemals
vermag und übrigens auch menschen nicht
es gibt immer wieder bilder von katzen
hunden die sie nicht zuordnen werden
können und eine letzte bei dem ganzen
hype googles katzen detector gemacht
wurde muss ich ihnen doch irgendwie noch
zwei dinge sagen die
der algorithmus weiß nicht dass katzen
nicht klar sind allerdings hat ja auch
keine idee der dreidimensionalität er
kann und vor allen dingen er braucht um
ist es qualität clustering zu machen 1,4
millionen beispielen die alle gelähmt
sein müssen mit menschlicher arbeit
meistens überhaupt erst als
trainingsdaten für die maschine
einsetzbar
das heißt also der ressourcen verbraucht
in die algorithmen des maschinen
learnings in ihrer trainings und in
ihrer testphase verbrauchen ist
ungeheuer und selbst das partner
universums mit dem ich gesprochen habe
ist endlich
ich finde dass diese ressourcen
verbraucht ein wichtiger punkt ist auch
wenn wir uns nicht beschäftigt hier ging
es mir nur darum ihn klar zu machen
unitis handeln in letzter instanz davon
das symbolische artefakte
denn hier geht es nicht nur katze hund
sondern katz und hund bilder das
symbolische akte ja als boomt mengen
in das regime gebrechen barkeit
einbezogen werden so ich komme weiter
und möchte jetzt zu an bereich ich habe
das mal phänomenologie genannt ich bitte
das nicht im positiven sinne zu
verstehen sondern schwächer
philosophisch schwächer es geht mir
jetzt um zeit auch im raum aber den raum
lasse ich jetzt mal weg
es geht mir um die entstehung einer
neuen computer generierten zeit vom
schnee so vor neben der objektiv
messbaren zeit und der subjektiv
erlebten zeitdauer
das sind die zwei zeiten die auch die
perks unterschied entwickelt sich als
dritter zeit modernität die
computergenerierte instabilität bzw
micro tempo realität der keine von
menschen überhaupt noch erfahrbare
zeitdauer entspricht
woide computer aktivität ein zeitstempel
trägt das könnte man wunderbar zeigen an
der engagiertesten technologie mit der
die suchmaschinen arbeiten bei der von
den ingenieuren gesagt wird dass in die
flächige repräsentation von daten in
form von zeilen und kolumnen sind die
tabellen das sind die tabellen die quasi
die die digitalisierung seite der la
place der erstes computerprogramm als
tabelle aufgeschrieben hat die
digitalisierung immer begleiten dass der
witz ist dass die zeit als eine dritte
dimension in die kolumnen und zeilen wie
man es sagt der daten zählen eingeführt
wird das aber betrifft jetzt nur den
zeitstempel betrifft nur die konkrete
art wie suchmaschinen überhaupt nur
damit fertig werden dass sich in jeder
sekunde über eine million neue patches
hinzu kommen bzw
geändert werden mir ist möglich um
einstellungen namen bestandteil der
computer arbeitet mit seiner halten
fonds rechenkraft so ungeheuer gestimmt
was für uns die zeit die form der
instanz kann ith annehmen
und jetzt gibt es etwas das mir sehr
wichtig ist daniel kahneman der nobel-
preisträger hat zwischen langsamen
schnellen denken und entschieden das
langsame denken ist für ihn das denken
dass mit argumentieren dass plan einer
reise aber auch dass schrift berechnen
und so weiter zu tun hat also das was
eigentlich mit den alphanumerischen
kultur techniken der schrift der
alphabetischen liste angst verbunden ist
davon hat er das schnelle denken
abgesetzt das beim menschen ins fast ins
banken funktioniert wenn ihr zum
beispiel das gesicht des nachbarn in
einer menge wieder erkennt wenn er die
stimme einer freundin wird und so weiter
und so fort es gibt also beim menschen
diese beiden typen an langsam und
schnell das eine ist das denken im
traditionellen schluss folgenden oder
wie auch immer sinne
das andere ist im bereich der bahnhof zu
gehen und was jetzt geschieht mit den
bedingungen der nico tempo realität ist
das ist der computer scharf diese
instanz anita die der mensch kennt
kleiner ob wahrnehmung auch jene
prozesse zu übertragen er also der hat
der suche etwa der informationssuche
dass das berechnend des argumentieren
auf jene prozesse zu übertragen die
bisher durch langsamkeit reflexivität
und distanz zum objekt gekennzeichnet
waren und deshalb hier eine parabel die
mir unglaublich gut
als medien denkerin unglaublich gut
gefällt von david foster wallace
zwei aus dem jahr 2005 schwimmen zwei
junge zwischen treffen zufällig an
älteren fisch denn der gegenrichtung
unterwegs ist er nicht ihn zu sagen
jungs das wasser ist zwar jung fische
schwimmen eine weile weiter schließlich
dürfte einige man handlich zu und sagen
was zum teufel ist wasser ich glaube und
diese parabel sollten wir nehmen als
eine charakterisierung dessen was
geschieht oder was der fluchtpunkt das
ziel des smart technologies jetzt das
erste wäre smart technologies sind
weniger als werkzeuge zu begreifen
denn als milieu unserer lebensform
zweitens der instanz geht und
unmittelbarkeit der menschlichen objekt
wahrnehmung habe ich eben schon gesagt
wird auf informationssuche und
problemlösung übertragen und schließlich
die in der alphanumerischen liberalität
mit langsamen denken verbundenen
fähigkeiten der distanz und der
reflexivität schwinden möchte dazu auch
nicht mehr sagen klar ist westens ein
wichtiges kritisches hält ist
ich komme mir zu einem weiteren
kritischen kennt das ich black boxen
würde wir alle wissen dass vor dem
schloss er zum artig entwickelt sich
hinter dem bildschirm eine domäne
miteinander interagieren der computer
algorithmen protokolle also wichtig ohne
menschen dass die geräte untereinander
interagieren und in nutzerinnen nicht
mehr einsehbaren erst recht nicht
kontrollierbar ist also vor dem
bildschirm bleibt eigentlich in gewisser
weise ist sie alphanumerische
liberalität natürlich ergänzt um einige
zusatzfunktionen wie den link gelten
sich selbst bewegen die schrift
aber vor dem bildschirm haben wir immer
noch bewusst in unserer alphanumerische
liberalität
hinter dem bildschirm entwickelt sich
automatic etwas ganz anderes und deshalb
möchte ich jetzt nur als ein beispiel es
gebe unglaublich viel dazu sagen muss
ich mir alles und das drücke nun komme
es auch gleich zum ende
ich möchte ein einfaches beispiel nehmen
von den wieder von den lernen
algorithmen und künstliche intelligenz
in konvoluts econ solutions gefaltet das
finde ich deshalb wichtig weil auch
leibnitz monat gefaltet waren weil die
spaltung eine oberfläche vervielfachung
stattfindet der auf kleinem raum größere
oberflächen zu gewinnen sind also das im
jahr algorithmus der conversion network
nach der trainingsphase verkörpert den
ohrring also der algorithmus kann ist
hund katze
mit 90 unterscheiden kann nicht mehr als
ein menschen verstehbaren erhält
rekonstruiert werden dh es gibt heute
die extern ebay ist die techniken das
bank doch zu können also das interne
modell das in den verdeckten schichten
eines gefalteten neuronalen netzwerkes
entwickelt worden ist
doch zu erschließen aber die normale
situation ist die dass die im
sogenannten maschinen lernen der
künstlichen intelligenz die algorithmen
ein modell entwickeln das nicht mehr ich
wiederhole es jetzt noch einmal in den
menschen schirm verstellbarkeit in das
menschliche neuen z zurückgeholt werden
kann
natürlich es ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass
weil ja die trainingsdaten aus unserer
praxis übernommen sind auch alle
diskriminierungen die unsere praktischen
bestimmungen bestimmen automatisch vom
algorithmus übernommen werden und dann
auch praktiziert werden und auf diese
weise will selber erkennen können wo
überall in den trainings daten
versteckte diskriminierungen auch
rassistische vorurteile wirksam wurden
und damit ist also ebenfalls ein weites
welt angesprochen ich sage schon es ist
jetzt hier nicht länger zu erklären
sondern ich gehe zum allerletzten
schritt und der ist auch ganz
programmatisch zukunftsaufgabe ist eine
digitale aufklärung im
spannungsverhältnis von garten
mündigkeit oder daten souveränität was
auch immer das heißt von
datenschutzbestimmungen
deren letzte form bestimmt nicht die
sein kann mit der wir im moment
konfrontiert dass jedes mal werden wir
eine page auf rufen wir zu akzeptieren
müssen was mir auch immer ganz nah
akzeptieren wir entmündigen uns also in
diesen praktiken und effiziente
handapparat technologien verfügen noch
nicht über eine strukturen dieser
digitalen aufklärung es gibt dazu
natürlich sehr viele ansätze mehr ist es
nur wichtig dass wir gerade bei der
unter rassistischen gesicht punkt so
sozusagen die aufklärung so
diskreditiert ist möchte ich ganz
explizit sagen dass die aufklärung
natürlich noch niemals einen
gesellschafts zustand gewesen ist
sondern ein telos das heißt ein programm
ist dass wir in unseren praktiken zu
berücksichtigen haben und insofern bin
ich ein vertreter der fortbildung der
europäischen aufklärung also es geht
darum die europäische aufklärung weiter
zu entwickeln und die richtung in die
wir weiter entwickeln müssen ist ganz
klar bestimmt und unterlegt und den
bedingungen des digitalen